I should make it clear that I was one of
many people that step forward on what
was a difficult day incredible to hear
gunshots high-velocity shots in
Parliament of all places it was like any
other day very bustling
Parliament the Division Bell had gone
we're all moving towards the division
lobbies in the main chamber and and then
to hear the gunshots the sounds it's the
the the whole Palace was subsumed by
chaos and panic and then to move forward
and find the professionalism of our
police force who had already established
a gun line pointing towards the carriage
gates to keep to protect the rest of
Parliament from any further attack and
then to see PC Keith Palmer on the
ground losing a lot of blood with
officers trying to help I simply move
forward to see what I could do we had a
pulse it was clear that I offered I said
I was trained as a medic and and and
could I assist and and they said tell us
what to do and I then as with all these
situations your training kicks in and
and we did our best to try and stem the
flow of bleeding and cut back the the
flak jackets and so forth call for help
get the medics in the medics asked me to
continue working and then the helicopter
arrived and the doctors turned up as
well and I was expecting him to be put
in the helicopter and taken away but no
you have to stabilize the body first and
I was again I was asked to continue and
it was very distraught then too to find
that much as where everybody everybody
had worked so hard that we weren't able
to keep him alive
unlike the true professionals they are
the the medics realizing that this was a
bigger scenario that so many people
being killed on the bridge grabbed their
medical equipment and moved out onto the
bridge to help those who have been
affected they're leaving a few of us now
with all the streets isolated in a very
eerie silence
having to come to terms with with what
was a very very sad day indeed in these
circumstances I mean you were carrying
at chest compressions I believe in
mouth-to-mouth doing everything that you
could and the doctors asked you to
continue on with that there is that
moment doesn't know when someone has to
call it but you don't want to hear that
do you you just want to continue on for
as long as you possibly can that is what
you want to do you don't want to be the
person to call it and I was very
grateful there was a a professional
doctor there to tell me it's actually to
stop and then as I say he got his kit
along with the others and moved straight
to the bridge to see what emergencies
you know could be provision could be
provided there as well it's a I mean a
year's reflection there's there were
more terrorist attacks as we know
Grenfell and so forth
it shows what dangerous timers were
living in and and I have such respect
for all police officers I'm from a non
armed forces background there's a
fraternity a sense of comradeship but I
see that that's absolutely reflected in
our valiant police force who you know
the officers get up every day say
goodbye to their loved ones not knowing
how their day will unfold and certainly
that wasn't it's absolutely the case
with Keith Palmer and yet they do their
duty and they were in this case they
protect us in Parliament and I was
pleased that the Prime Minister led the
tributes
to PC Keith Department for what he did
in service to to us in protecting us I
know that you were a captain and I think
the role green jackets which is where
your medical training had come from and
I was reading at the weekend that you
that you still feel now a year on you
you questioned whether or not there was
anything more that you or others could
have done but but the answer is no isn't
it you you you are faced with these very
difficult questions of course and it was
an extremely difficult day and all you
know I can do now is to say what a
challenging world we now live in very
sadly I was affected by a personal
incident in 2002 when I lost my brother
to a terrorist attack and I think I
think what also is challenging for me as
the
we live in a more ever dangerous world
the more volatile more difficult to
predict world and we need to step up we
need we need to be valent we need to
lean into this
in fact the reaction by everybody
whether it be in Manchester or indeed
London Bridge was actually don't let the
terrorists win don't let them have their
day but us to be determined that our
communities will be stronger for it and
not be divided but we are seeing as we
saw with what happened in Salisbury
police forces do their duty our armed
forces do their duty as well but I think
there is we need to ask ourselves as a
nation is there more that we can do and
what it seems to be a very changing and
dark chapter that we're enduring John in
the Bali bombings and very soon after
what happened at Westminster we saw
Borough Market you talked about
Manchester inor attacks as well in
answer to the question that you've just
posed what what is the answer what more
can we do this is something that I think
as a nation we have to ask ourselves
there are few states in the world that
have the ability and the desire to step
forward we're seeing resurgent nations
doing their own thing we're seeing
non-state actors - hasn't disappeared
extremism is still there you were still
going to get terrorist attacks unless we
lead we've done it in the past we've
endured harder times and we're measured
not just on the successes of this
country but how we deal with the
challenges and we need to - I think
regroup on this and work with our allies
and recognize that unless we do state a
step forward then these will become
norms the interference in elections the
interference in cyber attacks and so
forth the conduct of war is changing
around us and further attacks in in the
UK could very well be inevitable unless
we stand up to this and I think we have
the ability to do that and not just from
Isis of course we've seen other attacks
from from other and we don't know
exactly who carried out attacks in
Salisbury but we need to be as a nation
always I think the phrase is alert but
not alarmed that's exactly it but
Britain does more than that you know
there's this phrase that we use that you
know we sort of keep calm and and and
and and we do carry on with our lives
you don't want the terrorists to win but
we have to I think we have to do more
than that now we have to recognize that
there are a few nations in the world
that will stand up to tyranny that will
stand up to you know protecting the very
rules that have actually guided our and
supported peace for the last relative
peace for the last three or four decades
but that is starting to erode around us
and I think we we need to look forward
to the future and sort of revisit that
sort of Churchillian spirit that has
seen us endure
bigger challenges in the past you have
to very deep scars from the effects of
terrorism how do you not allow that to
instill itself as hatred in you I think
this is it is is is recognizing that if
you did allow that to happen you
actually allow the terrorists to ring
they want they want to divide us they
want to cause hatred they want us to sow
the seeds of doubt and we need to remind
ourselves that actually what Britain is
about is something very different we we
uphold the rule of law we are the
professionalism our own forces of our
police and so forth is an accolade as a
measurement for which other countries
around the word judge themselves on and
if we let our standards drop then the
terrorist does win and that would be a
bad very bad day indeed what do you plan
to do tomorrow the there are so series
of services that are taking place it's
going to be a very summer day for all
parliamentarians but again I think a
recognition that tributes and thoughts
and prayers to the friends and family of
PC Keith Palmer but and also recognition
that the our police force do an
incredible job in Britain in keeping us
safe and particularly in Parliament